pottsy they give us this function
we have to do some groundwork first but
a lot of the groundwork there I just let
you look at part 1 and part 2 I want you
to notice how much we want you to get
this question right can you tell have I
have we trained you well enough if mrs.
Lee's and I given you enough clues when
you look at it can you see they show you
where the turning point is and they even
tell you what kind of turning point it
is they tell you there's a point of
inflection they don't even ask you to
show that it's there they just say hey
this is a point of inflection there it's
because they're trying to get you toward
plant 3 even if you can't you know do
part 1 in 2 you've got enough actually
that's just been sort of it's a running
start yeah
so let's just write down some brief
notes for what you need to do so you
don't panic ok part 1 show that f of X
is a minimum turning point at so what's
the very first thing you need to do
we're not anything under the working
what I just want the steps you're gonna
have to differentiate right when you
differentiate you're gonna need to have
at least two rules in your head you're
going to use both of them when you
differentiate these things you're gonna
need the plats rule and there's another
one yeah you're also gonna have to use a
very simple version of the chain rule
therefore e to the X on to okay so
you've got those pieces of knowledge
that's fine okay you're going to get a
derivative out of that oops
what do you do with that derivative
what are you doing it
you're searching for a turning point
right so where my turning points
possibly occur when the gradient is zero
right so I'm going to say turning points
I'm gonna say May by the way may occur
when the derivative is zero whoops when
by the way not that it's that big a deal
but why do I say me it could be a
horizontal point of inflection right so
that would not be a turning point which
is the thing that I'm looking for okay
you're going to solve for that you're
going to get next value out namely this
R you've done at that point
are you finished to get the two marks
would you give two marks to a question
and answer rather that stops there
you wouldn't right what's it missing
it's missing a couple things okay I'm
gonna have to go and get that Y value
now they give you the Y value but it
says what's the word and the question
that tells me I have to find it
sure thank you very much right they've
given it to you but you still have to
actually evaluate and get this value out
of your equation okay so now got an x
value I've got a Y value am I done
what have I shown at this point
I've shown that at this point f dash x
equals zero do you have a minimum
turning point yet you do not you have
you have a stationary point but as I
already pointed out that could be a
horizontal inflection so what has to
happen next one or two things you've got
to test it right and you've got two
choices for how to test this what are
your two choices first derivative second
derivative have a look at the function
which would you use or which did you use
when you differentiate this thing right
it gets bigger because of product rule
and it's gonna get bigger again because
of product rule so I think rather than
differentiate again even though there's
no question rule or anything like that
I'm gonna go first you do do your
neighborhood test you find your minimum
now you're fine
okay yeah it was a lot of work for two
marks but keep in mind we gave you the
answers right so now we're up to par -
given that there's a point of inflection
sketch the graph and all the features
are there okay I'm gonna rub this off
how are we going to piece this together
try yourself a set of axes if you
haven't already
[Music]
so this is the only time out of the
questions that I've pointed out that
they actually told you to graph so it's
going to look something like this that's
been to your life now what are you going
to put on here one of the two features
you've already been told I've got a
stationary point and it's a minimum so
one two three you would put the
coordinates onto this because you do
know them what's the other piece of
information that I know about have a
look look read the question you're not
gonna read it for you they hand you a
piece of omission what is it the point
of inflection now they give you its
coordinates on the page it's at negative
five right so it's over here and if you
actually evaluate over there you'll find
it's just a tiny bit higher that makes
sense right why should it be higher just
put inflection because it's a minimum
that you're right next to you okay
you're gonna need a little bit of extra
information what else can you find what
else might be handy when you're graphing
what are like important features
intercepts are kind of handy I'm pretty
sure there's one at negative one and I
think is it one yeah okay so you're
getting a general shape here do you see
what's going on okay now look again at
the question it lists out a whole bunch
of things right that it says hey we want
you to put this on stationary points got
those point of inflection got that
intersects with coordinate axes got that
what's the last thing it mentions
asymptotes how do you find asymptotes
you think about the limits as you
approach those big values positive
infinity or negative infinity what's
happening in positive infinity look at
the function when you approach positive
infinity what happens to this thing well
this thing gets enormous and this thing
also it gets enormous so just blows up
so there's no asymptotes happening there
what about on the other side what
happens when X gets really small sorry
really negative a thing
then this becomes negative infinity but
what does this become when X is really
really negative it becomes really tiny
now the question then becomes well which
one wins which one wins so this is
growing at a linear rate right but this
is decreasing at an exponential rate
so which one takes over the exponential
is going to take over and another way
you can test this if your intuition if
it's not enough is you've got a
calculator there right just throw a
value in negative 100 negative a
thousand convince yourself that y equals
zero is going to be your horizontal
asymptote okay can you see the picture
yet can you trace it out of your mind
that's a bit weird I passed through the
horizontal asymptote what's up with that
can I do that absolutely I can because
the horizontal asymptote only matters at
the extremities in fact in this case it
only really matters at one of the
extremities this one over here I'm
pretty sure I can see a shape can you
see it here we go
there we go
done okay you happy so they gave you a
clue by naming all those features in the
question itself there is my graph all
features that are required are on there
okay